[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with coven 19 the opioid epidemic hasn't
disappeared it's gotten worse my drug
addiction is meth and heroin I've been
using at a very young age since I was 13
years old I don't have many relapses
left in me I'm 41 this is pretty much my
last chance I'm 38 years old and I'm a
recovering addict that is that American
behavioral health systems my role is to
go around and make sure the programs
have what they need administrators of
each facility are following our
procedures and processes and we treat
about 1,500 clients on any given day
normally today is not normal world this
whole hallway all the way through has
the ability to manage and house any of
our potentially sick clients I work very
closely with Tony Prentiss and his
colleagues at an American behavioral
health systems there's so much of
addiction recovery is rooted in
connection and community and coronavirus
has really decimated the ability for
individuals to connect in person which
is so core to recovery we've had to
minimize the interactions with our
clients so no no boobs are bigger than
10 our community meetings are no longer
held now their programming is more
specifically with their counselor
throughout the day and not as a
community so yeah we've limited all of
our recreational activities
[Music]
we first heard about the pandemic people
were a little scared in here about it
coming inside and thought it was gonna
come inside something that I was really
concerned about was having newcomers
coming in from the streets constantly
you know we're hearing the rate of
people out there that were infected and
whatnot I think one day we had up to 8
or 10 people run out the side door you
know and it was you know by the grace of
God I stuck around I think the recovery
would be a lot better if it weren't for
covin when you've been covering your
feelings and whatnot with substances and
alcohol first thing you come back is
your your emotions that's probably a
toughie thing for me
I miss the weight room I miss me and
it'll give my buddies a hug when they
leave in them I'd have to say the most
beneficial part is probably by my group
I can say anything are there I'm not
judged I mean there's certain things
that we're not doing that we'd only
would be doing but at the end of the day
this is one of the only places is still
doing it you know this place is doing it
for everybody and I I commit this place
for it
I'm most proud of the staffs willingness
to come to work every single day work in
a behavior health field on the front
lines which they're not getting credit
for being frontline workers but they
absolutely are and our staff have done a
phenomenal job of adjusting to this
we're struggling just like every other
behavioral health company is I'm sure
our census is down about a hundred and
forty clients from normal daily
operations right now grow in the fact
that we've had to buy all this bpe gear
so a VHS is one of the largest if not
the largest provider of substance use
disorder treatment in Washington in part
because they contracted the Department
of Corrections and so they've actually
seen a significant reduction in
individuals receiving care currently due
to koban with the course not really
operating in Department of Corrections
they're not getting into the system I
think there's gonna be a big need for
behavioral treatment
when we start to open up because they're
not giving services now and we are a
service that's desperately needed
throughout the United States and our
officials need to recognize that and
they need to do everything they can to
promote the treatment that's necessary
and support those programs not just a
BHS but every program get the people who
need help into programs because you're
seeing this spike out there that isn't
being addressed it's being ignored
[Music]
totally learning how to love myself
again it's been a big struggle in my
life and I think that is where it lies
with me I'm here because I've struggled
doing this stuff and my way thinking's
not good if you're out there struggling
on the streets using drugs right now and
with the isolation out there I'm sure
it's worse right now that it's ever been
in a while
don't ever give up if I truly believe
that if any one of us and your can get
past the choices that we made and work a
program or recovery I think that a the
sky's the limit for any one of us you
know so if you know anybody struggling
with addiction of any sort
be there for them and have their back I
look forward to being able help the next
person oh I'm grateful for my
opportunity
[Music]
a lesson in small table as it's not
crazy to cut off a steel titanium boy
whom three pounds of more he'll nog
cincuenta sections fostered in OPEC
okonomiyaki fighter not internal thing
[Music]
[Music]
about science fiction those flashes are
killing the virus and we have good
evidence from the lab that those that
that UV light does indeed kill that the
massage Co v2 virus which is the virus
that causes carbon 90 it's not a perfect
solution because even though shall we
say that the train is completely clear
of viruses at five o'clock in the
morning